then i see you kicking yourself over  there over that free throw but what were  you thinking when yana's got that last  look  look look look at that last look  uh yeah we're in good shape  him that far away from the paint is  obviously much better than him yeah  exactly anytime you can stay in front of  him and force him to  you know take shots like that you know  you just have to live with it you know  you can't  you can't guard everything and obviously  he's a force in that paint area and dave  was  troubles the whole night but you know if  you keep him out of there and  deandre did a good job of cutting him  off and forcing him into that  and we'll live with the results  the others  [Music]  situation  [Music]  your personal